we're joined Now by Indigo rumbolo from
just stop oil thanks for coming in what
do you think you're achieving with these
um
incredibly
disruptive and also dangerous protests
hello and I'm sure you'll agree we're in
an incredibly grave situation with the
climate crisis so just stop oil has one
simple demand and that is that the UK
government put an end to licensing new
oil and gas in the UK but but I'm
interested to know about these tactics
what evidence do you have that blocking
the busiest Motorway in the UK causing
endless disruption for tens of thousands
of people is actually achieving anything
we need everybody to come to join us so
we don't have to cause this type of
disruption on on the motorways we need
to be sat outside Parliament with tens
and tens of thousands of people
demanding an end to new oil and gas
yes but you don't need to resort to this
kind of disruptive behavior because what
it seems to me what people are talking
about indigo are your methods and not
your message so your message has been
completely lost because of the methods
that you are using which is in which are
infuriating people and disrupting life
or so many people so the climate crisis
is disrupting people around the world
around the world right now and even here
in the UK this summer we saw the effects
of the climate crisis with the UK
getting 40 degrees Heat
and birds falling out of the sky and
pensioners dying before they should this
is just the beginning and the climate
crisis is going to get worse and worse
and worse unless we act but we know and
we know that we cover that on the news
we know all that I'm just talking about
these tactics the message you have the
message that you want to get across get
completely lost I mean your message is
certainly lost on the woman who didn't
get to hospital for her stroke treatment
your message is certainly lost on the
patient who didn't get the hospital for
her cancer treatment appointment and
your message is also certainly lost on
Tony bambry the man who missed his
father's funeral so I guess my question
is
what is the point of doing it like this
so it's very clear that the disruption
will end as soon as the government
issued this statement to stop new oil
and gas but we will have to continue
because at the moment I just do not know
what else we're going to do do you have
any other ideas of how we could get our
government it's not for me to give us a
statement to end your oil and gas
because this isn't an issue of just
green policy or just the climate
protesters it's an issue that's going to
impact you it's going to impact me it's
going to impact your children of course
if you have children
impacting people around the world so our
government's decision to go ahead with
new oil and gas with the full knowledge
that this will kill millions of people
is a complete Act of betrayal but we're
talking about here now the tactics that
you are using I mean listen to what Tony
Banbury said these people have forced me
not to go to my father's funeral and
it's not like I get a second chance I
will never forget what they have done
and I will never forgive what they have
done so my point again to you is that
the way you are going about this means
that people are not listening to the
message they are just talking about the
method and they don't like the method
it's a very serious situation
but we know that well I'm talking about
the tactics you are using listen to the
police officer Chief Constable of Essex
he says this I think it is only a matter
of time before before somebody gets
killed the only way this is going to
stop is is if just stop oil frankly grow
up and realize that they are putting
people's lives at risk doesn't he have a
point that you need to grow up before
someone gets killed because you're
making your point you can make your
point in other ways so the way I see it
we're completely addicted to fossil
fuels have you ever tried to ask someone
to stop smoking
so I've asked my dad to stop the smoking
and that's because I loved him yes and
he was told that if he keeps smoking
he's going to get cancer and what and
the scientists will tell him you know
he's going to get cancer but it's not
very pleasant process no one second one
second could I could I just finish
asking me about the disruption and I I'm
accepting that's in your closet yeah I'm
accepting that it isn't Pleasant and I'm
accepting that we feel empathy for all
of those people out there but what we're
trying to do is to get everyone to come
together to get our government to Stop
Licensing the oil and gas in order to
save life but there are ways of doing it
that this void tens of thousands of
people having their lives just two weeks
ago a third of Pakistan was underwater
the rains have failed in Somalia for the
fifth year in a row meaning mothers
cannot feed their children I know that
and we covered that we had
correspondence out there there is a cop
27 conference you may have been covering
it but the media has failed to make
political change politics has failed us
I'm 28 this is the 27th cop conference
and what has happened every single year
the emissions have risen and risen and
risen if you were doing your job
properly everyone would be out on the
street so we haven't they're not so I
really want you to understand do you
know how great the situation is I do
understand the wonderful children I've
got children do you love those children
Indigo please I understand the point
you're making you are here today to
justify the tactics your Effectiveness
you love those children more than you
love yourself committing a crime why
shouldn't that's what we're asking you
so we're asking you to side with young
people who who are asking are government
very politely in line with the UN saying
that we need to come off fossil fuels
with the knowledge that we're going to
go over 1.5 degrees and this will
undermine the rule of law we're asking
people shouting at me to just look you
are breaking the law your protests are
law breaking why should you be allowed
to interfere with the rights of ordinary
law-abiding people going about their
daily business that's the question let's
let's me and you we can come together
we'll put a referendum up and it'll say
would you like to destroy much of life
on Earth including everything you know
and love or would you like to not would
you like your government to insulate
your house give you an affordable public
transport system tax the polluters who
are making money of people who are
starving and cold and hungry in their
homes this winter do you what do you
want to do so destroy everything we know
37 making this point why you're a cop
27th that is
at this point or not there are more oil
lobbyists at cop27 than there are people
like you why aren't you there making
your point yeah and and back to this
idea isn't that disgusting testing
why do you imagine that think about my
dad when he was smoking imagine if the
cancer research invited Benson and
hedgens into their you know into their
debate on what they're going to do about
them Indigo answer me this what do you
achieve that's disgusting I haven't
asked a question yet oh ask me this what
do you achieve by attacking things
people hold dear things people hold dear
like works of art like statues what do
you achieve by that honestly
yeah you've asked me a very reasonable
question what do you achieve so we've
been disrupting the art galleries we've
been disrupting football matches we've
been disrupting the M25 and we're saying
the media is not doing their job
properly and they're not telling you the
truth about what's coming down the line
the governments are not acting so we
need people and come together
that we're going to pass over this
threshold of 1.5 degrees of warming
we're going to plummet towards total
Destruction
so go on climate programs and talk about
sort of build a cop 27 and talk about
that but there are people across this
country who are fed up with having their
lives disrupted by your people and if
you want to talk about what just stop
oil is what is just stop oil do you just
stop oil what now
when how soon do you want to just stop
that's a really good question so the
economy it seems to me and I'm sure
you'll agree is driven economies around
the world are driven by oil so when do
you want to we will agree there are more
things that are important than the
economy won't we
would you agree then yeah
so let me explain let me explain the
demand because I think you'll find it
very very reasonable all we are doing in
in order to stop the disruption the
government would have to say we're going
to stop issuing the 130 new licenses for
drilling in the North Sea and we're
going to say no to the pending Coal Mine
decision
above the busiest Motorway in Britain
you've said it I mean the other thing
you said
you've got rid of some of truss's toxic
Legacy one second you you you've put it
you put it you put fracking away he said
what a silly idea she's brought in this
new fracking well now he needs to say I
have an opportunity here to go to the
cop conference and say Britain is going
to lead the way we're going to stop
drilling for New Orleans you said in a
newspaper the other day in order to
protect your freedom your rights and all
that you love will you stand with us now
it seems to me that what you were doing
on these motorways and what you're doing
um to cause the police no end of problem
and what you're doing and risking your
lives as well as people's lives on the
motorway
people are not going to come and stand
with you people how do you expect people
to come and stand with you if you are
disrupting their lives to this extent it
doesn't take this to get your message
across okay so
um if it wasn't for women like the
suffragettes I wouldn't have a vote I
couldn't own anything I don't think I or
every right in Liberty that we have your
working rights my rights to vote as a
women woman they have been fought for
they weren't just handed down by people
down from those with power they were
fought for and every single one of those
Liberties that is at risk because of the
climate crisis okay
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much